if you want to hear my theory about how
one of these characters could be back in
a future installment of saw that stick
around to the end of this video this
video is sponsored by audible Bizet's
audible.com slash zzs world to get
started and get your first audio books
for free one of the most interesting
things about the Saw franchise is that
nobody has ever portrayed without major
flaws even among the so-called good guys
there is perhaps no better example of
this than the father and son pair Eric
and Daniel Matthews
welcome to horror history my name is
death Belle Delphine and I will be your
instructor today as we cover eric and
daniel neither his father and son first
appeared in saw to but their story
stretches back much further than that so
let's take it back Eric Matthews was
born in the late 60s or early 70s he
would become a homicide detective for
the Metropolitan Police Department known
for his uncompromising attitude where he
was well respected earlier in his career
but his crumbling home life eventually
seeped into his job he had trouble in
his marriage some time after he and his
wife gave birth to their son Daniel in
the early 90s though the first cause of
the marital troubles is not known it was
likely that Eric's infidelity was the
final straw before his wife filed for
divorce in 2000 these home issues had
begun to manifest themselves in his work
life the first known incident happened
when he broke his suspects jaw with his
flashlight he has also been criticized
for gunning down an unarmed suspect and
planting evidence on criminals in order
to get an easier conviction it was
around 2003 when Eric had an affair with
his female partner Alison Carey not only
did he lose his marriage because of this
but he also stopped working with MS
Kerry and lost custody of his son who
was entering his teenage years daniel
began acting out and i think it was
because his father was a cop that he
chose a life of petty crime to get back
at him the seriousness of these crimes
rode the line of a punishable offense so
Daniel managed to stay out of juvie in
2005 while still in the process of
getting the divorce the media caught
wind of Eric's foul wind that sounds
nasty a Casey ud2 news crew confronted
him one night about rumors of police
brutality causing Eric's snack loot
ality what brutality ha
what brutality what
not only was Matthew suspended for
excessive use of force and implicated an
evidence tampering but the news footage
appeared on the TV documentary and only
worsened his already waning reputation
if we take a look at the meltdown meter
he was basically at the level of Elmo's
[Music]
Eric never really got back into the
field after his suspension instead
opting to take desk work and causing
several Otello cops to question his
dedication to the job that would change
however when the other side of the law
made things more personal in October of
2005 Eric received a call that his son
had been caught shoplifting at a store
called superior electronics he picks him
up and he's unable to get through to
they just end up arguing it was Eric's
turn to be in charge of the kid but
Daniel decides he'd like to go back to
his mom's house early and he storms off
without saying goodbye Daniel never
makes it back to his mother's house
though he is abducted by a man named
Bobby who was working for a criminal
he's just starting to pick up some
notoriety in the city a man known only
to the public as jigsaw when Daniel
wakes up he finds himself in a room with
seven other criminals and notices that
they're being recorded by a video camera
the last to wake up is a woman named
Amanda who finds a key with a hidden
tape recorder that tells them that
they're breathing in a deadly nerve gas
that would kill them in two hours but
the doors to the house would not open
until three hours had elapsed they are
tasked with finding the antidotes hidden
around the house a couple of clues are
given
you all possess the combination to the
safe they card the numbers are in the
back of your mind the clue to their
order can be found he also tells them to
think about what they have in common
and as usual x marks the spot so in true
pirate fashion the first guy to try to
escape gets his face blown leaving
Daniel and the others to scavenge the
halls of the nerve gas house for more
clues and before you type your comment
telling me to look for clues yes I'm
aware I look like Shaggy get over it now
the reason that Daniel is being tested
is not specifically stated it could be
for not appreciating his time with his
father who really just has the kids best
interest in mind but it's probably
because he's veering off into a life of
crime because part of what they all have
in common is that they've committed
crimes even if the ones that Daniel
committed are much less severe than the
others many of the victims who make it
out of jigsaw strats are rehabilitated
and began to cherish their lives after
they recover daniel is probably one of
the best examples where you can see him
changing in real time as he watches the
big guy Xavier trying to smash down a
door you can see Daniel flinching with
each and every head with each strike
Xavier pounds the door he's also
pounding the picture of how scary life
in prison can be into the teenagers hat
another thing to note about the scene is
that Daniel is the calmest person out of
the group and perhaps the reason that
he's able to last longer in the nerve
gas house than any of the others is
because he isn't doing as much heavy
breathing also jigsaw doesn't typically
test kids though I would love to see one
of those spin-off series where it would
basically be called saw babies or some
streets but despite perhaps being in
less danger early on in this game the
others would soon make a discovery that
made Daniel Matthews the biggest target
of all
jigsaw the evil mastermind of the Saw
franchise managed to outsmart his
opponents with his razor-sharp intellect
so what if the opposition had been a
little bit smarter if only they knew
about audible audible is the leading
provider of spoken word entertainment
and audiobooks 27% of adults haven't
read a single book in the last year and
the main reason is lack of time with
audible you don't need to find time
because you can just listen to the audio
books whether they're about engineering
human psychology or just straight-up
entertainment you can listen to stuff
while you're out shopping while you're
at the gym gardening or just to kill
time if you can't do any of those things
cuz you're locked in the quarantine
right now I'm checking out misery one of
the most beloved books by our boy
Stephen King I've always enjoyed the
movie but I've just never had time to
pick up the book and who would want to
pick up a book I mean it could be
contaminated see John Kramer was
definitely onto something when he made
all those tapes for his victims I want
to play an audio book well John all you
have to do is head on over to
audible.com slash CDs world or text
Easy's world 2 500 500 that will give
you the option to start a 30-day free
trial which includes a free audiobook
that you get to keep no matter what
once again that's audible.com slash C's
these worlds you'll find that link in
the description or text Easy's world 2
500 500 after one of the women Laura
finds a secret basement daniel joins the
group to investigate and they find a
mannequin with a note for hobby
explaining the rules of his furnace trap
where he was unsuccessful in obtaining
two antidotes
Laura's starts getting woozy after this
and Daniel encourages her not to stop
and rest he offers her a sense of
optimism which shows jigsaw that the way
he behaves with his dad is really just a
result of him lashing out and he is
genuinely a good kid Daniel asks Amanda
why she was chosen for the game and she
tells of how she was a junkie who was
once framed for possession but Daniel
does not yet know that it was really his
father who put her behind bars
that's gonna be an awkward conversation
if it ever comes up one of the other
guys comes to let them know that they
found an unlocked door and Daniel
displays his kind heart once again by
helping the deteriorating Laura down the
stairs the next game is for Xavier but
he selfishly throws a man into the pit
and stuck which Daniel bravely helps her
climb out of even the shadow of Xavier
is deteriorating sanity as they search
for the next room the group tries to
figure out one of jigsaws Clues by
determining what it is that they all
have in common
the only shared thread seems to be that
all of them have
yeah all of them except Daniel but as it
turns out Daniel is the very reason that
each of them are linked the reason is
unveiled when Laura finds the axe x
marks the spot
shut up that meme is outdated the x
marks the spot of the photograph proving
that Daniel is the son of Eric and each
of these criminals clearly remembers
Eric Matthews is the man who framed them
and got them locked up so they aren't
too happy with the whole Matthews family
in general to be fair though they still
all did commit crimes they just weren't
the same crimes that each of them was
imprisoned for and to be honest it's not
like the teenager Daniel really has any
control over the actions of his father
so maybe they don't have to be upset
with them nope they're still mad Laura
didn't last long after that Xavier goes
off on his own and begins hunting down
the others so Amanda takes Daniel under
her wing they barricade themselves back
in the original room and discover a
trapdoor under the safe Big Brain Daniel
is the one to remember that when Amanda
originally found the tape recorder there
was a key alongside it and that key is
good to unlock the trap door and gain
access to the basement at this point
Xavier is picked off all the others and
he chases after them in an effort to
collect the numbers shaved into the back
of each of their heads remember the clue
the numbers are in the back of your mind
eventually they make it to the bathroom
where Daniel does what Adam did in that
very same room one year earlier and
plays dead in order to gain the upper
hand with a surprise attack and Xavier
so yeah
Daniel kills a man at age 14 or however
old is let's give it up for Daniel for
being a bat don't even type up in the
comments for Xavier let's just give a
big fat bro in the chat for Daniel what
a little trooper with that the game is
over
Daniel's health is dangerously low so
Amanda gives him the heart container I
mean a dose of antidote to get him
through until the doors open we don't
actually see this happen but I'm
assuming that's what goes down because
the needle can be found later on
Amanda helps Daniel get to safety by
transporting him to jigsaws Workshop at
the Wilson steel plant where he's given
an oxygen mask and stowed away in a safe
I'm guessing the oxygen mask was both to
help him clear the nervious from his
system and to keep him breathing in the
tiny air space of the safe where he
would stay until the following day later
that afternoon eric is feeling
apologetic about the argument he had
with his son and tries to get a hold of
him but is obviously unsuccessful his
former partner and Mistress Alison Carey
calls him to the scene of a murder and
the victim is a man named Michael marks
and informants that Matthews had used in
the past upon arriving at the crime
scene Mathews is too
even though this is someone that he
knows he just doesn't seem to care a
whole lot I think this is because his
head isn't in the moment he's thinking
about his relationship with the Sun he's
distracted by the pressure of his wife's
lawyers and being around Carrie probably
reminds him of his biggest mistake or at
least what he thinks is his biggest
mistake at that point it's not until
Carrie pointed out that he notices
jigsaw has left in a little message roll
it the closer detective Matthews
kind of what
that's what I wrote
Carrie spends the rest of that day
trying to bring him onto the jigsaw case
but Eric can't be bothered with it
telling her about all the other stresses
that he's dealing with still the images
of that crime scene stuck in his head
that nights until eventually he has an
epiphany the steel used in the trap
reminded him of a case from his past at
the Wilson steel plant the next day he
finally gets out of the office and turns
up in person for the SWAT raid at Wilson
steel thinking he's gotten the upper
hand against jigsaw he leans in close
and asks this is close enough this line
demonstrates Matthews obsession with
power which is one of the reasons that
he's in this mess in the first place
he can't just catch jigsaw he has to
gloat over him but little does he know
the battle has only just begun unlike
the previous criminals he was able to
frame arrest and drop easy convictions
on Eric Matthews has finally met his
match with jigsaw Matthews men are about
to take John Kramer away but John tells
him he'll need to remain in place while
Eric deals with a problem in the other
room a series of monitors showing the
events of the game in the nerve gas
house Eric doesn't recognize the other
criminals that he'd put away over the
years but he does recognize his son so
he confronts jigsaw in a rage
John simply asked Eric for some of his
time for a one-on-one talk and promises
if he can do that he'll get his son back
[Music]
secure state that a little pun from
jigsaw because Daniels in a safe
literally in a safe his first instinct
is to attack jigsaw again this tells us
a lot about Matthews even without seeing
much of his past in the Canada
psychologists often use a person's first
reaction to make an analysis about them
that's why those Rorschach tests are
helpful to make a diagnosis showing Eric
Matthews his son in danger is
essentially jigsaws Rorschach test when
Eric threatens violence John reminds him
that he's already got cancer so hand to
hand violence seems pretty insignificant
to him jigsaws game is to simply test
Eric's restraints if he could sit there
and talk to the man who is responsible
for his son's kidnapping he would pass
but if he resorted to dirty tactics like
he did to arrest the other criminals who
had been in a nerve gas house and the
other victims of his police brutality he
would be punished Matthews is quickly
losing his patience though so Kari tries
to get him to take a logical approach by
threatening to destroy the blueprints of
jigsaws tracks but when Matthews takes
this into practice he takes the big
angry create a spectacle approach which
is no match for John
cool casual intelligent tactics to get
your conviction without all this
evidence the difference in Matthews
approach and what Kerry had in mind is
symbolic of the difference between a
good cop and a dirty cop as well as the
difference between someone who has
studied jigsaw and understands him
versus someone who is actively avoided
what would become the biggest case the
city has ever seen John's intention is
to tactfully point this out and make
Eric realize the error of his ways so as
a clue he tells him to look inside a
drawer in the other room which contains
the arrest files of everyone in the game
unfortunately for Eric he still doesn't
get the point and when he notices Xavier
going after Daniel and Amanda on the
monitors loses control and goes full
bash reverse on the meltdown he goes
into the room with John alone and beats
him up and breaks his finger he breaks
the walkie-talkie and what I see as an
attempt to communicate to John that he
no longer wishes to play by the rules if
food out is what it takes Eric is more
than willing to go there when he sticks
his gun in John's mouth John has seen
enough he offers to take him to the
house where the game was held if Eric
had just held on and done things by the
book for a little bit longer he would
see that the game on the screens is
already over and his son is tucked away
safely when they arrive at the house
John gives Eric a key which he uses the
storm in and find the photo of him and
his son he ends up searching until he
finds himself underground in the
dilapidated bathroom polluted by the
bodies of those tested and failed before
him and clouded by Eric's dark
desperation and to locate his son I
would guess that this clouding is the
reason he momentarily lets his guard
down when he sees a pale hand at the
edge of the bathtub perhaps thinking
that Daniel was incapacitated under the
robes and pigments in reality it was
Amanda who injects him with the powerful
narcotic before he got the chance to
retaliate he next wakes up unarmed with
a chain around his ankle tethering him
to a pipe against the wall the exact
position that Adams Stan hight had been
left in one year earlier beside him he
finds a tape but unlike the tapes he
neglected to study during the previous
investigations of jigsaw murders this
one emanates with the voice of Amanda
young who condemns him for framing her
on a drug charge for which she was not
guilty amanda has become a disciple of
jigsaw and Eric was her first test
subject the final words of her tape say
now you're locked away helpless end
alone and I find this to be an excellent
example of the punishment fitting the
crime after putting so many guilty
people behind a bar
the easy way by fudging evidence Eric
would now be the one who's locked up at
the mercy of one of the people he is
wrong as this is going on time expires
on Eric's game and the safe back of the
steal plan pops open setting Daniel free
after having passed his test with
jigsaws games there is always a chance
for redemption and Amanda's first game
would be no different he finds a
flashlight and a hacksaw looking around
the room tells him what his options are
he sees the bodies of Xavier and Adam
and the foot of dr. Gordon he could
choose to take the easy route and spend
the rest of his days in the bathroom or
suffer through the pain of the trap and
hurt himself to escape Matthews gets the
gun but it's not loaded he's unable to
bring himself to cut his foot off but he
finds the toilet lid and uses it to
crush the bone in his foot so that he
can slide it out of the shack I mean I
guess he did this because it's faster
but it doesn't really seem like it would
be less painful at all
I mean it seems like it would be more
painful let me know in the comments what
you would prefer that he's able to do
what my cousin was unable to do after a
hefty Thanksgiving dinner and make his
way out of the bathroom but like my
cousin his suffering for that evening
did not end there because Eric Matthews
would encounter an enemy on the other
side of that door detective Matthews
after finding a pipe that he uses as a
crutch continues to search for his son
Daniel but what he finds instead is his
captor Amanda and the two engage in a
physical altercation Matthews finds
himself in a position to take her out
before his broken foot becomes an issue
and then he bites Amanda's leg for some
reason he gets a hold of Amanda and it
seems his old ways have not changed
because he tries to beat the location of
Daniel out of her she refuses to
cooperate and he's about to finish her
off when she goes for his weak foot and
scrambles away Amanda is going to leave
him like that but even in excruciating
pain Matthews true nature shines through
and once again he can't just leave
things be
amanda comes back and we don't see
exactly what happens after that but
jigsaw would later describe her actions
as leaving him for dead
so I'd say she most likely attempted to
kill him she even believes that he's
dead after those events but he's
actually able to survive somehow
partially thanks to John Kramer going
back into the house and as he puts it
cleaning up Amanda's mistake what
happens next is not really in line with
the usual treatment of those who
survived one of jigsaws games then
rather than immediately attempting to
convert matthews into one of his
followers I think John realizes that
Amanda's tests did not work on Matthews
he had not rehabilitated like the other
survivors had because he still tried to
use force to obtain a location of his
son after escaping he's put into his
cell down the hall in order to reflect
on his crimes where he's given an orange
jumpsuit to bring him down to the level
of those he imprisoned he's also given a
foot brace and he's periodically fed
some kind of goop through his small
slots Matthews is deliberately kept
alive for the next six months and he
makes a very little friend his
confinement would end on April 28th 2006
when he's taken to the Gideon a
meatpacking plant for another game
another chance at redemption
he's forced to stand barefoot on a large
block of ice with a noose around his
neck as a timer in the room counts down
from 90 minutes as he takes in more of
his surroundings he realizes that his
fellow officer
detective mark Hoffman is strapped down
to a chair beside him another man walks
into the room and pulls a chain which
activates a contraption in the ceiling
above Matthews eventually after all he
had been through he can't take it
anymore and steps off the ice block to
try to off himself and end his own
suffering this gets the captors
attention and he picks Eric back up onto
the ice block explaining that if he
doesn't way down the block the water
melted off the ice will run downhill and
electrocute his friend detective Hoffman
Eric reluctantly decides to stay put not
wanting to sacrifice the life of another
just so he can take the easy way out
this part highlights the dynamic aspect
of Matthews character in his first game
he's made out to be selfish and lazy but
he clearly does care about his son and I
think the same can be said about his
comrade Hoffmann with just under 20
minutes left on the timer Matthews
pretends to lose consciousness
once again drawing the attention of the
captor but this time uses the close
proximity to attack him he holds his
feet down once again saving Hoffman from
electrocution and tells Matthews and
left the winning
he divulges a little bit more
information telling Matthews and Hoffman
that there's another guy being tested
and if he passes all three of them get
to go free
by making Eric stand on the ice block
for 90 minutes jigsaw is testing his
will to live after being locked up for
six months with the next phase of the
game he's gonna test if Matthews learned
anything in their previous game if he's
learned to restrain himself and let
justice play out as jigsaw intends it to
or if he's going to interfere and take
punishments into his own hands like he
did with the seven criminals and like he
did with jigsaw back at the Wilson steel
plant to do this jigsaw has instructed
the captor to hand Eric a gun and a
bullet with 19 minutes and 6 seconds
remaining he gives Matthews the power to
make his own choice on what he wants to
do with it when the timer gets below 1
minutes their captor takes out a red
button which is supposed to release them
from their traps after the time expires
as long as the fourth guy doesn't come
through the door Matthews spots the
other guy running up beyond the
translucent glass and tries to yell out
to warn him not to open it but with just
two seconds left the man SWAT officer
rig who is another one of their fellow
law enforcement guys charges the door to
break it down as a last-ditch effort
Matthew shoots the glass but this would
not be enough to save him upon the
opening of the door the contraption is
released and two huge ice blocks swing
down and crush his head putting an end
to his long six months of suffering in
the end it seems that Eric Matthews
story is kind of a tragic one
in the beginning he's stubborn and does
things his way but ultimately pays the
price for it having to break his own
foot and suffer six months of solitary
confinement to survive only to make it
to a test where he suffered even more
only to find out that his life was in
the hands of officer Rigg the whole time
I think the argument can be made that by
the time Rigg came through the door and
Matthews actually had rehabilitated in a
way he shows an act of selflessness by
helping keep Hoffman alive even when he
no longer wanted to go on and he managed
to play by the rules during the second
game one thing I find interesting is
that jigsaw victims usually do have some
kind of chance to redeem themselves but
Matthews life seemed to be entirely in
the hands of Rigg the event of Rigg
coming through the door and Matthews
firing the gun all happens at once so
I'm wondering if maybe it's possible
that Matthews was actually given a
second chance maybe there are actually
two requirements that must be met in
order for the ice blocks above his head
to be released the first one is
obviously for Regan to come through the
door before time expires as for the
second let's say that there's a
microphone in the room someone used to
detect any loud noises
140 decibels so if Matthews ends up
firing the gun the device detects that
as the second requirement to release the
ice box of course this isn't shown
anywhere in the movie this is just an
idea that I had but I think it falls
more in line with jigsaws values so that
ends the story of Eric Matthews but
perhaps the Matthews name lives on
because as far as we know Matthews son
Daniel is still alive as we know
survivors of jigsaws game often become
his followers his disciples the ones to
carry out his legacy perhaps we will see
Daniel Matthews again in a future Saw
movie or perhaps we already have at the
end of sauce at spoiler alert if you
haven't watched that for some reason and
yes I'm aware that it's called soft 3d
the final chapter or whatever I prefer
to call it saw seven but yeah at the end
of saw seven we learned that dr.
Lawrence Gordon has been helping jigsaw
behind the scenes all along and he
captures Hoffman with the aid of two
masked henchmen now I know in the
deleted scenes it turns out to be these
two cups but there's a reason that the
scenes are deleted and intended
storylines do change as the Saw series
plays out sometimes as far as I'm
concerned the identity of these two is
still up in the air as far as the cannon
goes for future installments in the past
I've theorized that one of them could be
Logan Nelson but I think another
possibility for the true identity of one
of these henchmen could be none other
than Bradley Donovan I'll see you all
tomorrow night it's assuming we both
survive
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]